the streets of LA manga don't feel like
they belong in one of Spain's most
famous natural habitats this Festival of
1960s and 70s architecture
orbit encloses Europe's largest
saltwater Lagoon
Mar Menor the little sea its shallowness
and high salt content produce a singular
ecosystem
Pedro Garcia has spent much of his life
trying to preserve it years ago he says
this stream would have been a trickle
now it's a near-constant flow
it has altered the conditions of a
lagoon that used to be salty losing an
important part of its characteristic
ecosystem which is very fragile and this
has had environmental but also serious
social and economic consequences
for Pedro and other activists the main
threat is intensive agriculture since
the 1990s water has been diverted to
irrigate what was a dry landscape that
water takes nitrates from the Farmland
into the mar
several times in recent years it's
caused algae blooms sucking out oxygen
and killing sea life
another threat lies higher up where the
legacy of this Region's mining history
is still in evidence Arsenic and heavy
metals remain in the scarred hillsides
the past couple of days have seen Heavy
Rain severe flooding in this region this
is what's been left behind up here at
the site of the old mine and if you
think about all of that excess water all
of that runoff carrying whatever
pollutants it might have picked up here
it's only going in One Direction
downhill towards the Lagoon
such events have driven law professor
Teresa vicente's years-long battle to
Grant Marmon or the legal status of a
person a battle she's now won
now we recognize that the the nature is
the center of the light and has value
enough to give right and then now the
big company can do
things until that the right of nature is
the limit
close by University scientists are
creating a living insurance policy just
in case seahorses and other marine life
from Marmon or are being studied and
bred to keep stocks in reserve for
future reintroduction the hope is they
won't be needed
is a long distance race and considering
how the regional and National
governments are working I think with all
the measures as a whole we can get Mom
and all to recover
the regional government told us it was
reducing fertilizer use removing algae
and improving the sewerage system
the new legal status for this place at
least gives its Advocates another way to
hold those in power to account
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera Mar Menorah
southern Spain